the united nations general assembly in
new york is an important staging post on
the way to the cop 26 climate change
summit which is being held in glasgow
later this year at the summit we're told
the focus will be on coal
cars
cash and trees and today it's cash in
the spotlight
that's because back in 2009 rich
countries pledged to give a hundred
billion dollars per year from 2020 to
support poorer nations as they adapt to
the effects of climate change
but that target has been missed the most
recent oecd report estimates that only
79.6 billion dollars in public and
private funding has been delivered so
far
america had taken some of the blame for
that promising just 5.7 billion dollars
a year which critics said was nowhere
near enough given the size of its
economy but now america has promised to
double its annual contribution to over
11 billion potentially encouraging other
nations who might have been holding back
to do the same
the us now joins the uk which has
pledged to deliver around three billion
dollars a year over the next five years
as a climate leader in finance funding
why does all of this matter so much well
the cop 26 climate meeting is just weeks
away and developing countries like
indonesia and others have said they are
willing to consider tougher carbon
emissions targets but only if they are
funded as promised to them it's a matter
of trust and good faith it may be just a
number but that 100 billion
really matters